good morning everybody and welcome to
this
licensing act subcommittee of
mid-suffolk district council
on the 4th of may 2021
this subcommittee is called to consider
an application for a new premises
license
in respect of the regal theatre
ipswich street stone market
i'll just quickly go through the rough
outline of the procedure there'll be a
few formalities
but generally the um the licensing
officer will outline
the application um
the applicant will then present their
case
and then once that's happened other
persons who've made representations
will they be able to um put their their
case forward as well
throughout there will be an opportunity
to ask questions
following each of the the presentations
and answer those questions obviously
just a reminder that you're asking
questions specifically on the
representations that have been made
before you then the
closing submissions will be made the
applicant will have the last say
and then members will go into private
session to make their decision
uh just make quick reference to the the
regulations regulations
15 and 16 of the licensing act 2003
hearing regulations of 2005
provide for the attendance of parties to
licensing hearings who may address the
subcommittee
and if permitted by the chair ask
questions of the other parties at that
hearing
i shall now hand over to the the chair
of the subcommittee council guthrie
thank you
thank you very much uh nigel and welcome
everybody my name's kathy guthrie
um and as just announced i'm the chair
today thank you
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to youtube and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consented to being recorded
by the council
and the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press
are not lawfully excluded the etiquette
is that
please ensure the microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
and the video turned off that you do not
interrupt other speakers that if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt
you may be asked to leave additionally
you will be invited to speak and ask
questions behind me so please await your
turn
may we have apologies for absence please
none receive chair and declarations of
interest by councillors any declarations
yes chair if i'm a cancer stringer um
uh i am a volunteer director of the john
peel center
which has been the host venue for the
regal during the recent building works
at the regal
thank you for that councillor counsellor
and the introduction just so that
everybody's clear on everybody
i'm mrs kathy guthrie i'm the chairman
today
we have councillor ms helen geek
thank you and councillor andrew stringer
and we'll just have a look at councillor
stringer are you there
you were a minute ago i'm here now jay
yeah we know you're there we have the
legal advisor
nigel lulu licensing officer kay
sanders licensing officer
kath ruden green and committee officer
karen sayer um
the applicants i would like you to
introduce yourself please if you would
um and uh you'll
uh if you would like to make the
introduction to yourself and anyone
that's with you for this
please
so that's mr blackburn yeah my name is
david blackman i'm tom clark stone
market
town council i'll be supported by david
marsh the town council's events and
theater managers
and he is also on the webcast is he
i believe so yes mr marsh are you there
hello yes i am thank you yes
and um can you just confirm that you've
received
um the procedure and reporting copies of
all the relevant representations
that are required yes that's correct
thank you and now may i ask your um
self mr andrew parking to come back to
us um
yes good morning chair my name is andrew
parkin i'm a resident
of temple road which is adjacent to
the regal thank you very much indeed
thank you
so does anyone here wish to withdraw the
application or their representation
no thank you for that
thank you and if you can switch off your
videos that would be great
so um k to the licensing officer
have the banana requests for the party
for permission to call witnesses
no chair thank you
have the parties indicated they wish to
present documentary or
other material no chair thank you
so um mr blackburn how long do you think
it will take you to
give your presentation
um it should be within the realms of
about
seven to ten minutes maximum chair
lovely thank you
and to um mr parkin how long will your
representation take place
please i would hope sort of
five to seven minutes lovely thank you
very much indeed
so now we can ask kay to present their
report mla
sub 200 oblique one and summarize the
matter
under consideration if you would like to
present your report please
thank you chair this hearing is to
determine an application
made for the grant of a new premise
license made under section 17 of the
licensing act 2003
by stone market town council in relation
to the premise the regal theatre ipswich
street stone market
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 15th of march
2021
a copy of this is attached to the report
excuse me as appendix a the application
made has been subject to the statutory
consultation period as prescribed by
regulation
the notices advertising the application
have been on display at the premise
and published in the east england daily
times on the 27th
march 2021 full details of the proposed
activities and timings are contained
within the application form
as attached as appendix a the operating
schedule steps proposed by the applicant
to promote the four licensing objectives
are listed in part m of the application
form the premise currently hold a
premise licence which was granted in
2005.
this application for a new premise
license is required due to the expansion
of the site
a hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of a
representation which has not been
withdrawn
subcommittee will be aware that its
consideration is confined to promotion
of the four licensing objectives and the
need or commercial demand
for licensed premises are not
considerations for the licensing
authority when discharging its licensing
functions
licensing authority must carry out its
functions under the act with the view of
promoting the licensing
objectives which are the prevention of
crime and disorder public safety the
prevention of public nuisance
and the protection of children from harm
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
secretary of state there may be a period
of time
when the local statement of license and
policy is inconsistent with these
revisions
in these circumstances the licensing
authority will have regard and give
appropriate
way to the relevant changes guidance and
its own statement of licence and policy
the subcommittee will also be aware of
human rights act 1998 considerations
specifically article 6 for the applicant
and articles 8
and 1 of protocol 1 for those raising
representations when determining
applications for the grant of a new
licence
the license authority has received no
representations from any of the
responsible authorities under the
licensing act
environmental health as a responsible
authority under the act have undertaken
mediation on their areas of concern and
the outcome of their mediation is
attached
as appendix d to this report
there has been one representation
received made by other persons
which includes local residents
businesses
and or residents associations this is
attached as appendix c
subcommittee must have in regard to the
representation
such of the steps if any as it considers
appropriate
for the promotion of the licensing
objectives that's to
grant the license subject to conditions
which are consistent with the operating
schedule
accompanying an application modified to
such an extent
as the authority considers appropriate
for promotion of the licensing
objectives
and subject to any mandatory conditions
which must be included in the license
to exclude from the scope of the license
any of the licensable activities to
which the application relates
or to refuse to specify a person in the
license as a premise supervisor
or to reject the application
any party agreed by this decision taken
by the licensed authority in respect of
this application
has a statutory right of appeal to the
magistrates court
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed so i'll
firstly ask mr blackburn and then mr
parkin
firstly mr blackburn do you have any
questions uh to the officer
i don't thank you mr parkin do you have
any
any questions to the officer uh no thank
you
thank you and now um councillor geek
do you have any questions for the
officer no i don't thank you
and councillor stringer none at this
stage chair
thank you for that so now we can ask
um mr blackburn on behalf of the town
council to present your case please if
you would thank you
thank you very much chair there's two
parts of this presentation the first
part i'll introduce the application the
second part
i'll move on to the objectives concerns
which i'm sure the subcommittee will
expect me to to address
introducing the application then the
regal theater is one of three cultural
and entertainment assets in the centre
of stone market
along with the museum of east anglian
life and the john peel center for
creative arts
uh ambitions plans have been developed
to improve each of the three venues
one of hopefully a series of significant
steps forward will be taken
with the end of the construction phase
of the regal theater
redevelopment project which is due to be
completed
in a couple of weeks time the building
has been at its present location for 85
years
since it first opened in 1936 and is a
popular community venue
there has been a premises license in
place since 2005
under the licensing act 2003
details of the current application are
contained at appendix
a within the agenda papers it should be
noted that the hours applied for
are less than in the previous license
notwithstanding the major redevelopment
that has taken place the sale of alcohol
is very much
ancillary to the main purpose of the
building which are for cinema
theater community use and use of the
cafe
by the public
the consumption of alcohol outside the
premises will largely
be during the intervals of theater
performances
and live shows and the occasional gala
premiere of a film
in appropriate circumstances in addition
the terrorists may be used by customers
for a drink on a sunny day
this arrangement has been in place for
over 16 years
and has been characterized by a pattern
of responsible and civilized behaviour
on the part of customers indeed
during the theater manager's time at the
theater over those 16 years
he can confirm that he has not had a
single incident to deal with
arising from the consumption of alcohol
outside the premises
an outdoor noise management plan has
been developed
through the input of the environmental
health team this is included at appendix
d
within your papers and contains a
comprehensive set of measures with
regard to deliveries
customers queuing to gain admission and
customers leaving the theater
playing in music and a restriction that
customers may only eat and drink outside
the premises
until nine pm it should be noted that
the introduction of a 9 pm
limit on the use of the outside space
within the application has been done so
voluntarily when the license over the
previous 16 years
permitted outdoor consumption of food
and alcohol
up until 11 pm that summarizes
the application chair
i would like then to move on to the
comments about
criminal activity if i if i may
um i suppose like any tale there's been
evidence of shifting patterns of
criminal activity in stone market in
recent years
for example evidence of drug dealing has
been found near the high school
the mix the parish church and the
recreation ground at various times
there is no suggestion that any of these
amenities are badly managed or
are actively contributing the problem to
the problem of drug dealing in any way
it is just that those buildings and
locations
act as useful landmarks for those
involved in
certain forms of illegal activity
so that they can meet up similarly it is
our reasonable belief that the problems
encountered on temple road
are not directly attributable to the
operation
of the regal the subcommittee will be
aware of the duties imposed by the
licensing act 2003
paragraph 1.9 of the mid-suffolk
district council statement of licensing
policy also acts as a reminder of the
constraints of the licensing process
it says that the licensing process
can only seek to control those measures
within the control of the licensee
licensing law is not a mechanism for the
general
control of anti-social behavior by
individuals
nor is it a cure-all for community
problems
if a license holder has taken all
appropriate steps to promote the
licensing objectives
while carrying on authorized licensable
activities
and there is no causal link established
between the pro
the problem in the locality and specific
premises
and it is unlikely that the licensing
process is a
mechanism to address them the guidance
on the licensing act
also states that a representation
related to general crime and disorder in
an area
will be deemed irrelevant if it cannot
be linked positively to the particular
premises
from our perspective of the applicant we
would suggest that there is not a causal
link between any aspect of the
management on operation
of the theater and the presence of
anti-social behavior
or criminal activity on temple road
we do obviously however recognize the
genuine concerns
uh by expressed by mr parkin
and believe that this is a matter that
can only be addressed with the
continuing support of the stone market
safer neighbourhood team we have liaised
with stone market
snt inspector neil mckay and community
engagement officer pc stephan henriksen
as we agree that it is in the interest
of both mr parking
and the town council that police action
is taking to deter
and disperse any criminal activity that
is happening
close to our respective properties
the town council recognises the duty
imposed on it by section 17 of the crime
and disorder act and we hope
the steps that the town council has
taken to increase the number of cctv
cameras on the front of the premises
from one to four and upgrade the image
quality to 4k
ultra hd will help evidence to be
collected to support any police
investigations
in summary whilst we don't believe that
any aspects of the regals license
application would actively contribute to
public
nuisance or crime and disorder in the
area
we do intend to continue our
constructive dialogue
with mr parking and the local police
concerning the steps that can be taken
to address the issues being faced in the
area
david marsh and i will be pleased to
answer any questions that
you or the chair or the subcommittee may
have thank you
thank you for that mr blackburn so first
of all excuse me i'll come to mr parking
do you have any questions to the
applicant
um the only question i have to mr
blackburn is he makes reference to the
premises
of old which was a very small building
with very low customer turnover
the building which is now proposed and
opens in may
is significantly bigger so the number of
customers i would expect would be
you know at least one hundred percent um
on top of the current numbers so there
will be a much bigger
number attending the venues in all
aspects this mr harvey
what's your question do you have a
question you'll be able to make your
representations
so my question is when when we talk
about there be no incident sorry chair
you know that's fine talking about no
incidents based on
low numbers based on high numbers you
always will increase
higher incidence that's rather a
statement than a question
but noted thank you all the same you
will have your opportunity very shortly
thank you right um so um
councillor gate do you have any
questions um for mr blackburn
i've just got a couple to do with um
location of activities um
could you just confirm where exactly the
outdoor areas are for alcohol and music
are they the terraces to the right and
left of the main entrance or have i
missed anywhere
no they're on on the terrace as you as
you say yes
and the other one is that um the queue
in the past the queue has been out of
the side stairwell
into the car park and and now the side
stairwells aren't
aren't there anymore so where are you
envisaging the queue
to to happen when it does
could i refer that to david marsh
because
he's got a handle on the operation of
the building when it
opens thank you chair
uh yes if i if i may uh yes the new
queue will be
will go uh go around the uh kind of but
the new bar structure um on the car park
side of the of the venue so uh
yes there's a there's a paved area where
that will be able to take place
so it won't be on the pavement
no uh there's kind of i i don't if
you're aware of the yeah there's a kind
of glass frontage on the on the new
regal
um and so it will kind of it will curve
around there so it won't be
it won't be in the kind of road of the
car park if you like um but it would it
would go around
it would go around that area um
sorry i think i'm being a bit dense are
we coming down the stairs at the front
is it possible for us to put a picture
up so that we can see it is it possible
at all
the officers just to clarify it
yeah just bear with me for a second and
i'll get it thank you
i've managed to completely misunderstand
the plan in that uh
well that's why it's a good idea to ask
the question and to see the plan
so that we all know what's what yes how
to clarify easing down just a minute
wait until if you just wait a second
um mr marsh until the um officer shares
the
um screen and obviously members of the
public can see this as well
karen are you able to help him with this
you sent me a copy of it
i can if kay isn't able to locate it
would you like me to help kay
yes that would be helpful um if you
would if you could just share your
screen with that up on the screen
there you go there it is could you has
somebody got a pointer that
um they could just assist as um mr marsh
tells us about it
so mr marsh do you want to tell us where
from where the hand is at the moment
where this
counselor geek has questioned thank you
yeah so where the hand is where that
curve
where the kind of the curve is next to
that that's where that is where the
queue will be
encouraged to uh to queue now
i see so that's um yes
so to a certain extent it's impinging on
the outside
um entertainment areas yes we would that
isn't where we would
the um the seating would be kind of to
the right of
slightly to the right of where that the
handle is but yeah so it wouldn't
it wouldn't uh we wouldn't be blocking
any uh any entrances
et cetera by having having a cue there
we don't think
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you for your question counselor geek any
further questions
no that's all from me thanks thank you
um councillor stringer
yeah just one we have in appendix d
uh amplified and non-amplified music how
that's going to get be mitigated
in the outside areas
is there any uh mitigation or any
controls on
any noise coming from inside the new
buildings because obviously the new
buildings are closer to residents
than the formal ones thank you
if if if i may chair um because
obviously we now have three
we have three screens and we uh we don't
impinge on the uh on our neighbors but
we also don't wanna
impinge on the uh on the other screen so
we don't
need to be able to hear one film while
you're watching why you're watching
another so
um real um we we we've taken uh
lots of advice um um on on these kind of
sound dead and in between screens
so it will be significantly improved uh
to what
you know to the noise if any that the
neighbors had to kind of
part with before uh there is significant
uh sound
deadening and sound engineering so uh um
we don't anticipate there be
any issues with regard to that okay and
on the outside mitigation it says the
hourly monitoring of the site separate
how will that monitoring be conducted
we have we would use the uh the sound
app to make sure that it's not too loud
we would
literally you know it would be uh uh
anecdotal going out and just does it
seem too loud and
uh and that that is the kind of due
diligence we would take place
i think the kind of the music uh live
and
and amplified is very much this would be
probably two or three times a year for
kind of when radio suffolk
kind of pass a visit etc this is this
won't be part of our kind of uh
you know every day we're not looking to
provide an en entertainment there is a
on a regular regular basis okay that's
helpful thank you
thank you for that counselor stringer um
i just have a question
um regarding the um
interim drinking should we say in
between performances
um and i note that you will be having um
plastic
bottles um outside
um is there anything to stop people
taking them
away from the venue and um into the high
street
or will they be collected and at the
source
if i may we we will also have a have an
offline off license as well but we would
but we would be ensuring that it wasn't
you know we
the whole point of it isn't to be kind
of uh selling to the
selling for people consume on the high
street so that that would absolutely be
controlled
thank you for that right thank you very
much
right now they're mr parking we'd like
to hear
uh from you if you would please thank
you very much
yes good morning chair thank you and i i
wrote my correspondence to you
in relation to is mr blackburn reference
the anti-social behavior that is going
on in temple road
and permanently around two areas one is
around this county line drugs
which you know the police have been very
supportive with but the residents
um do seem to get an awful lot of abuse
when they approach these individuals
but i suppose my concern is more around
the
ymca which is located behind the mix
there is a lot of vulnerable
young and minor
housed in that particular area and
they gather on temple road and
um my concern is is they will sit below
the raised tourist area where people
are proposed to be having their their
drinks
i think they'll be very vulnerable
they're already being targeted by
um these unfortunate drug dealers
that we have in our location
and my concern is mr blackburn raises
we're talking about a smaller venue
which is
you know lovely culturally received
within store market
now expanded to three times its size
and i'm very supportive of that i have
to say it as both gentlemen will tell
you
but when you start selling alcohol and
play music
live or recorded outside it adds to
another dynamic
we've experienced it with the
weatherspoons and they've changed their
their music from outside to the back
only from the front streets
i'm concerned about people buying the
alcohol
not necessarily consumed on the terrace
and taking it into store market where
it's a free alcohol zone
so all of these things are just for me
mitigations
of potentially what could be happening
based on it's another area of selling
alcohol
primarily inside i think it's a lovely
venue they've created a wonderful
cafeteria
that is a great area to serve during
intervals
and when you look at the appendix b and
which is the plan that we looked at
earlier chair
and as i look at the red hatched line
where there is
alcohol consumption it seems to be
everywhere around the
internal side of the perimeter of the
building whether it's plant rooms
whether it's disabled toilets whether
it's
corridors and so i do have a little bit
of concern about the control
of where the alcohol will be and
cctv is a wonderful thing but it's a
reaction rather a preventive measure
you know an incident is an incident
which can be removed
from happening the cctv is an incident
which has happened and we then take
repercussions
so i'd like to go back to the former
which is to try and remove
any incidents so for me it's around the
noise
it's around the abuse potentially the
verbal and foul language which comes
with
people having a good time we'll be
attracting
far bigger numbers from far further
afield than our local community and
store market
because we have to make the business
plan work in this case
so all of these and i'm just concerned
as a resident
and local residents who spoke to me
have the same concern around noise
behavior
and you know more on where do how do
people behave once they are consuming
alcohol and outdoors and
i just think is is a risk indoors
is much easier to control
thank you mr parkin um i will go around
and ask
people if they have questions to you so
for the applicant mr blackburn do you
have any questions
for mr parking please uh i don't chair
um thank you um councillor geek
any questions um no i don't think i do
thank you mr parking that was very clear
councillor stringer yeah just one check
uh you mentioned that the police have
been very supportive which is really
really good here uh is there any sort of
latest update on this or any response
from the police to this particular
application
um
thank you thank you um and i will just
ask the officers did the officers have
any questions um for mr parking
no chair thank you
um i don't specifically have
questions um so
um the closing submission
um if we would please um can i have the
licensing officer to give a closing
statement please
i think is it is the applicant
has the final say i beg your pardon i've
sort of assumed
um i do beg your pardon i'm so sorry uh
mr park and if there's anything further
you'd like to say at all
from what you've said there's only one
thing
i'm only referring to the sale of
alcohol externally
on the tourist area and for sale of
alcohol to be taken from the premises
i am supportive of the alcohol
internally
thank you very much indeed that was very
clear
thank you thank you so i will now ask
the licensing officer for the closing
um statement thank you
thank you chair um there are no other um
points to clarify
thank you very much to that so
everyone has had time to put forward the
case and i must put forward the
following motion on the basis
excuse me chair so the applicant has an
opportunity to have the last say before
we go into private session
we've only we've only heard from the
objector and the licensing officer
oh right i beg your pardon i'm so sorry
i'm jumping the gun so
mr blackburn do you want to have a final
say then thank you i do beg your pardon
very briefly chair uh the sale of
or the consumption of alcohol on the
outside terrace
is a tiny tiny part of this application
uh we
believe that well over 99
of the alcohol will be consumed within
the the building
um the teres will be rarely used
uh it's effectively an overflow facility
for a theater performance during an
interval where
where it creates extra space on a
summer's evening
and also when we have radio suffer go on
perhaps a couple of times a year
so as david marshall says that the
playing of music
is going to take place two or three
three times
uh perhaps during the course of the year
as a local authority
we have a responsibility to live in
harmony with our
neighbors so whilst it all sounds very
formal today and it's mr blackman and mr
parking it's actually andy and david and
we've been there
on countless occasions trying to talk
through the issues
and seeing what we we can do
the the um the way forward as we see it
is to continue the dialogue um we don't
believe
that the crime and disorder issue is
directly attributable
to um the theater in any way
there's no evidence of that happening in
the past and we don't believe
there will be any evidence in the future
of a causal link between the theater
and the problem if we manage the
premises responsibly
which we absolutely will do thank you
thank you very much indeed that was very
clear so we now um
come to the motion that i must put
forward which is on the basis that the
subcommittee
considers that the public interest in
excluding the public
outweighs the public interest in its
deliberation
being held in public and it's resolved
that under section 100a brackets iv of
the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for item six
on the ground that it involves the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in part one
of schedule 12 of the act on the ground
set out in regulation
14 brackets 2 of the licensing act 2003
brackets hearings regulations 2005.
may i have a member to second the motion
please
cancel a stringer
you're muted but i can see your hand
going up yesterday happy to second that
sorry it was jittering around on the
screen
yes it's difficult sometimes isn't it
thank you and um
councillor geek are you in agreement
with that too i'm in agreement with that
too
right in that case then the live stream
will be paused we will leave this
meeting
and convene in another room thank you
very much
and so um i will now ask nigel to advise
of our decision thank you very much
thank you chair um thank you everybody
the the members have considered
carefully the
representations made to them today both
written
and verbal having
heard all that has said the members are
satisfied that the issue
of the license with the proposed
conditions contained in the operating
schedule
are slightly amended which i'll refer to
in a second that we would not contribute
to any
existing anti-social behavior issues
issued in temple road
and therefore are granting the
application for the license
the slight modification to one of the
conditions is to the
condition relating to cctv
and at the end of the first sentence
which says a cctv system shall be
installed and maintained on the license
premises
with a minimum of three cameras covering
the license premises
she'll have the addition in brackets of
including the totality of the outside
licensed area of the premises that's
just to ensure that
the outside drinking area on the terrace
is uh 100
covered by cctv coverage other than that
the
the application is granted as apply for
applied for
um i just need to add that any party who
has made
representations on this application has
a right of appeal
to the magistrate's court if aggrieved
by the decision
such an appeal should be made in writing
to the magistrates court within 21 days
of receiving notice of the decision
thank you chair thank you very much
indeed
and so can i thank everyone who's
been present here today presented the
case listened to everything
and of course the councillors and
officers who've come well the
members have come to the decision thank
you very much indeed and i close the
meeting thank you
you